while you die for your mommy tell the  truth  [Applause]  the man cannot outrun his destiny  your mother soldier 15-pound you cost me  and you can learn that back I were but a  child yet I were already traveling full  tilt toward the man I would become  the legend makes you think I won't kill  you right now sure know the man you  pretend today I'd rather see to it that  your kind suffer either side of that  [ __ ] you call another only choice but  to lock your your son in Tennessee risky  he could boy you got their army a big  man  [Music]  you always wanna build an army  go to war the body bulletproof boys  many would call me the coldest blooded  murderer ever  but others knowing the truth would call  me a hero  and farewells this world always got left  is historian  you  you